on this episode I talk about design
changes what I would do with three
thousand dollars to build my business
and do I like being challenged
you ask
this is
ask Gary be New York Jeff thanks F this
is awesome so cool everybody this is
gary vay-ner-chuk and this is episode
205 the ask gary vee show i'm god we
snuck this one in i'm you know what with
the whole tyler and india thing like
like i think we're out of rhythm of like
scheduling i mean i have not been on a
pace at all with this show this has been
the dark ages these last 45 days so need
to get back on track
garrett thanks for holding up facebook
live good to see you guys how's that
going how many views we got summer nice
very nice quick to a thousand india it's
great to see you have you been good oh
well oh well great
you ready push oh i am did you see our
montage let's get into the show
I did not watch you visit it's great
should we should we can should we put it
like how long is it good good can can we
can we put it right here and it has to
be my channel click out Stephan you know
you've messed this up link it up link
this one up got it
we'll link up our montage oh I'm sorry
so let's add to our montage let's get
into the show nice one yeah nice and
solid that's a crazy crowd ease what is
that like salmon is that like salmon
that a salmon sweater yeah ok ok
Browdy make sure he put up his handles
up it everybody who's watching this show
go tweet Trouty nice salmon sweater yeah
let's do that
hashtag nice put that up Stefan nice
salmon sweater put his handle uh
actually really funny story about rowdy
his job Troutman I think his handle is
trow D which is Mike Trout the best
baseball player in the world or the
second best baseball player or Big Ups
Bryce Harper - uh most people that's his
nickname and most people think trout is
him like people every time Mike Trout
like it's two home runs the game his
Twitter explodes anyway let's get into
this show India James asks Gary I want
to snap and vlog my work but I'm mostly
sitting at a desk on my phone and email
how can I add variety in content well
you've got to be creative I mean you
know funny thing about this is there's a
crazy thing guys crazy thing about
creating content both for social media
both for television both for books both
for magazine articles
it's called talent there are plenty of
people that can set a desk all day and
produce amazing content because they're
funny they're clever they're imaginative
they are creative by Nature so my answer
is talent James you know you've got to
come up with an idea and like asking me
to give you the creative pillar is not a
good strategy because I could tell you
that you could do it all day long you
could do a whole series on snapchat of
like random websites like why don't you
just take your phone while you sit at
your desk and in between important
things go to stumble upon click a button
random website show it on the screen and
you audit those websites you add your
two cents social commentary to every
website on the Internet
you never have to leave your desk ever
again but are you good enough are you
funny enough
are you quick-witted enough one of my
most famous videos is what I cold called
somebody tried to sell them an ad
because I was good at it that's why I
was good content I just sat on my desk
and so I think the answer is too many
people think that you have to rely on
amazing scenery or having a mix
different day I think my snapchats all
the same [ __ ] it just like me and my
face of like wherever I am I'm trying to
mix it up I eat a banana here and there
now I'm going to weird bathrooms like
I'm trying but like like have you seen
that yet I've got it thank you I'm tryna
I'm trying to like I travel a lot I
think bathroom culture is fascinating so
you know well there you go so there you
go so so how would you even ask me that
what do you what do you hello let's
start over you just said one or two in a
really random like creamy bathroom and
use a fan from it and then like curating
a blog interesting yes super different
India anyway my man James anything can
be funny anything could be interesting
comes down to the talent if you're one
that needs the visual support well then
you're gonna I mean this is a binary
question meaning like if you're not good
enough in a mundane similar situation to
create something that's interesting and
intriguing well then I don't know you
gotta get a new job like something crazy
like I don't know you're stuck like like
there's certain truths like you're gonna
sit at your job and do calls at your
desk
it sounds like regardless so instead of
saying that's a defense make it an
offense it's a mindset unless you're
willing to change a job and travel the
world and have all this great scenery in
the background like buck up Charlie
James and and figure it out and you can
make a whole moon just about I can do a
whole thing just on Courtney at the
front of our like I can do all I can
basically make like I can basically make
anybody famous if I want to
what's up Gary
Sean Denver Colorado here see the
beautiful Rocky Mountains in the
background good washing fee is about
negotiation what are some of your best
tips for getting the deal done and
making sure that it's mutually
beneficial for both parties Sean it's
it's interesting great question thank
you for heeding the call for better
video better scenery in the background
sure there's a bunch that are pent up
from a month or two ago you know it's
funny they're one in the same I'm very
aggressive and I very aggressively go
after a person say look as quickly as
possible I want you to trust me
tell me what you want what is in your
vested interest if I can figure out what
that person wants and first I go with
honesty and you know it's funny when
somebody's negotiating with you they
don't want to give you honesty you know
and actually I use it as a tactic to
build a relationship if I go at somebody
and say look yeah and by the way you
guys know this with salary some of you
know this with salaries likes it like
it's how i'ma go she ate almost
everything it's like like I just want to
know like if I like because by the way
if you say hey I want to pay vaynermedia
four dollars a month and I want four
dollars a month well then we just saved
a lot of time like cool let's do it so I
think my best tactic is has been the
same which is honesty truth and
aggressiveness to extract the truth from
the other person you know I'm naturally
a counter-puncher right in my marketing
and definitely my negotiating it's like
what do you want to happen for how much
and and if I can get them into a
truthful place now one of the keys to my
strategy is drawing a line of sand when
I say to somebody give me your best
offer and if I can hit it I'll do it
if they then give me an offer that I
can't do I have to say no and I can't
move so it's just all grounded in truths
so I think you have to know what you
want and I think you have to try to
extract from the other person what they
want and you need to try to make them
feel comfortable that you're in their
best interest one thing I do is I point
to my career at this point and let them
know that I've done everything on
lifetime value that I don't need to make
it as much money up front it's all about
the long term and so I require that for
my people I require that for my partners
and so I just think the right way to go
there is go right at it
go look what's going to get
still done like for me I'd rather leave
profit on a table to get the deal done
quicker I think too many people want to
guess the higher number like let's say I
want eight thousand dollars for this I
think too many people like twelve
thousand instead of saying them how much
is it going to get done and Stefan says
seventy five hundred if I'm okay with
that even though I want eight thousand
Billy good done let's go speed movement
trust relationship get finding a place
where you could trust that person here
on the same page that's how I see it
Nishida asks Gary how did you sign
changes to apps that cause a negative
stir effect brand image or usage is this
back to Instagram I mean this stuff
happens all the time
remember when we were changed its long I
mean I think ubers new logos way worse
than its old one but that's one man's
subjective opinion even though all four
of you shook your head
do you like the Instagram one better now
no no yeah you got it yes I mean either
but like whatever like nobody gives a
crap if anybody still today cares about
the Instagram design change then then
they don't realize that Instagram is a
business and not a museum like like in
the context that I come from if you're
making art that you want debated for the
rest of time it really matters if you're
talking about business like everybody
complains about logo changes on sports
teams pro/con logo changes of apps
pro/con it's a fun thing to talk about
but if you noticed I got bombarded about
it on social and I didn't even answer
anybody's question about it because I
didn't even want to respect the question
because for me from a business
standpoint it has zero point zero zero
zero zero impact on instagrams business
now the UI and the UX if it makes people
stay on it longer engage with longer
that is huge impact but the logo itself
management factor it does have impact
like I'm not pooh-poohing design I mean
I believe in design for example I think
I'm using Instagram less like the first
week just because my I didn't recognize
the logo as much I hit it less times not
even kidding but I'm a focus group of
one I think net net in a 60 90 180 term
it doesn't matter I'm already back to my
normal usage on Instagram and so you
know listen it can be a an issue but I
think a lot of times
press over engages at for example like
when the gap changed its logo and that
was a hole to do and they changed back
or when people have to do that a lot of
times it's more about the press and like
the like perception and then the stock
price more so than what's actually
happening in user behavior but sometimes
it can be a change but I don't over
listen I think a aim and a logo can
always be trumped by the quality of the
product even bad press when uber is
getting all that bad press you know
you're my friends like oh I feel bad
what Oberer is doing and I like take it
over while they're saying it I'm a big
fan of actions over words all the people
that like I hate the Instagram logo but
are using it point three times more
today than they did a week ago like what
does that then mean it's like saying
you're moving to Canada if you don't
like the president and then not moving
which is what basically all my extremist
friends on the Republican and Democratic
side have done over the last 16 years
everybody moved to Canada Tory Bush
everybody moved to Canada during Obama
and so far nobody moved to Canada
because you're full of [ __ ] and that
that's just a higher level conversation
of like the logo what does it mean I
don't know a lot a lot of people like
the same things on social media I like
to know what you actually do versus what
you actually say yeah I put that it's a
VG finally yes you can sample my [ __ ] if
you can ask Gary you challenge the old
everyday how do you feel when challenged
from the young professionally tremendous
I'd love to be challenged more than
anything I think one of the misnomers of
a cult of personality like myself is
that we all love yes men and women
around us I can tell you that look I
mean you get the benefit of being right
you know one of things I hate about my
success and I'm not going to work
because I don't want to jinx my success
is the longer I have it the more of it I
have the less I'm being challenged by
the young or the less experienced or
less winning you know it's very
dangerous when you've accumulated
success
that you're not being challenged I love
challenging people and I love to be
challenged what I love most about being
challenges like eight out of ten times
that I'm challenged in something I
really know I feel like the person's
challenging me for the sake of
challenging me because they're playing
that role because they think it's going
to catch my attention but then I'm
actually in the game of the argument and
when they look like an idiot and they're
wrong by all standards
it actually makes them lose so I guess
why I'm painting you that little picture
is when I challenge I challenge with
substance like if it's funny that I just
talked about presence like politics
health care macroeconomic issues
geopolitical issues terrorism health and
wellness boy do I not challenge anybody
boy do I do a lot of listening and when
I'm at my worst occasional pontificating
about my opinion on it but boy you will
not see venom if we all have brunch and
we start talking about something I don't
know about it's stunning how quiet I get
it just you only see me in things that I
know you only see me challenging things
that I know of course I'm going to
challenge Seth Godin if I don't agree
with him cuz I know and so I love when
somebody I love when somebody challenges
me at this company and outside this
company when I can taste that they know
what they're talking about because then
you have some real frictions make
diamonds I want to get better I want
somebody to challenge me but when you're
going to challenge me that TV or direct
mails better and all you have is some
[ __ ] from 1984 and you're not a
practitioner anymore and you have
nothing to back it up
like you're gonna get eaten up I love
being challenged I want the young to
challenge me all day and you saw me show
me the episode with the 15 year old
girls from musically like I was
listening I don't need to like not
telling them they're wrong they're in
high school they're they're like all my
kids in my class are on Twitter I'm like
cool respect Wow you know so so that's
that and by the way that's a focus group
of one high school that doesn't mean
Twitter is now you know like everybody's
I know Gary do things Twitter is huge in
high school like I know I think it's an
interesting thing to pay attention to
because after that comment hundreds of
more emails and comments of people like
yeah it's true and my own school too and
by the way tens by the way just to give
ground you of like I don't know what
that girls talking about in my school
nobody's do it like so but tends to hunt
me that's one
Joey nice jet sign hey gary vay-ner-chuk
I saw in one of your videos you got
asked if you were to build a company in
2016 today from scratch what would you
pick
you know erase all your followers all
the companies that you built up to the
state you said you would choose
something like Nike so my question is at
the beginning stages of your company
what would you do for your three next
moves
what were your top three first moves be
to help grow your company and keep in
mind you only have $3,000 what would
those three status be good indication
semuc an export a Convention Center
inventory what would it be let me know
can't wait to hear your answer and thank
you for including my question in today's
show what's his name Joey Joey great
question look the truth is Joey and
everybody's watching and so many of you
are emailing me and please by the way
it's a good opportunity Stefan can you
put a little a little up video pop up of
like you'll do a little editing for this
one actually put a picture I don't want
to make you go a scary V the search
engine if you have business questions my
new search engine is unbelievable all my
questions all my answers transcribed all
they are in a search engine and so you
know so many questions about this and
truth is Joey you you clearly asked for
yourself there's so many things you
could be doing for your apparel business
I guess is why you reference Nike like
you know first of all I would say if
you're an apparel the number one thing I
would do is try to get Instagram
influencers to wear your product at zero
cost all the way up to 1.3 dollars $50
$100
I think influencers are grossly
underpriced so I think I think the game
is about exposure and conversion and I
think that too many people don't really
understand how to run a business make a
lot of bad mistakes I'm Anne Frank I'm
super pumped at shark tank is now doing
this after the tank TV show done if any
of you watched it but Lizzie loves it
like so like they're showing people
going out of business because they grow
too fast
they don't understand there's a real
cadence of growing it's it's like
anything in life like you can't get too
ahead of yourself you can't go
- slow you know it's funny a lot of
people when they start digging into my
content realize that I'm a real
contradiction that I believe in very
opposite points of view and and I think
my answer to your question is it's a mix
of a hundred different things I couldn't
give you on this show I'm not going to
give you what you want from this
question which is like these sweet
tactical things I'm I only give very
black and white tactical advice when I
actually have hours to sit down look in
your business I actually understand what
I'm talking about I don't want to look
like an idiot or have egg on my face
so then I talk about religious points of
view right so for you you need to get
that shirt and you need to get as much
exposure the same way you hacked your
way onto this show asking a question now
you've got exposure right I saw you put
your little snapchat logo down there in
the corner some people snap that
following you now you're looking for
exposure I think it's a grind right like
for apparel businesses are very hard you
need distribution you need awareness to
me what I would do is a lot of listening
I would tell you a very honest answer
joy if I were you and as young as you
look and you look great nice and young
super super fit dude oh and he likes it
um what you said yeah what no but like
you know yeah Debra Woodson oh yes
that's exactly right that's right he's a
fit man right yeah yeah super fit
exactly good yes wasn't a boy-girl thing
you just see fit um uh you know I think
that um I think that one of the things
that scares the living piss out of me
is that a young dude like you and so
many young dudes and dudettes like you
everybody's just jumping in and running
a business like you know what I would
tell you to do actually you know what
I'm going there screw it you know how to
tell II do show your business down and
go work for an apparel company for three
years
go email every CEO of an apparel company
that's doing over five million dollars a
year in revenue that you respect all of
them sit down grab a nice shake right
kale a nice kale shake and map every
single CEO in the world that has a five
million dollar a year or higher revenue
apparel business then go to LinkedIn and
Twitter and email
and tweet all of them and ask all of
them for you to be their chief of staff
right-hand man and to work side by side
with that person for the next 18 months
that's what I we do steak versus sizzle
there's no tactic that I'm going to tell
you in the askgaryvee show that's going
to set you up for success and to be very
frank with you and I don't wanna hurt
your feelings Joey and I have a lot of
respect for you and this is hurting
everybody's collective feelings my
intuition is somebody building a really
big business in the apparel space is not
going to rely on one of their tactics
being asking a business guru for advice
tactically so I would uh I would take
that 3,000 bucks and save it so that you
can live with 17 roommates while you
work for Carol Thompson and her nine
million dollar a year apparel business
and watch it up close and personal India
do it one more time and I don't do this
for humble bragging I think it's
important because a lot of you know
India know she's been our ecosystem one
more time four years I'm Vayner India
three weeks in my inbox say it one more
time
like different than you thought India
learned more like you know it's only
three weeks but like like just different
just different like and you can't buy
that India sat here on all goddamn shows
with you guys India's written a ton of
these stuff has probably consumed way
more of my voice than she would ever
want to yet in a 10-day period being in
my inbox being close to the Sun she
gained more context I wouldn't say
learned you know but like holy crap what
yes and that's why so many of you are
jumping to run a business and I'm a
natural good businessman like a lot of
you don't have as much natural
entrepreneurial DNA as I do I think you
need to learn from the hip and I think
the biggest mistake is you'd rather go
getting this is a different piece of
advice for a lot of the college kids
that I've reached through that one video
you'd rather go get that job at sixty
three thousand at the gap and be number
seventeen thousand even though your
ambition is to own your own fashion
brand versus making no money
teaming up with 19 roommates living that
ghetto lifestyle
but being the right-hand person of a
remember it's far if you want to start
your own fashion brand isn't it much
better to be very close to a person
that's got a three to five million
dollar a year business because that's
going to be your first step even if you
at the right hand of the CEO of you know
Nike or adidas or Under Armour or coach
like that's not the company you're going
to build you're going to learn corporate
America skills so like I'm just
completely pissed with the lack of
movement like it's a lack of patient
it's much cooler to say you're a founder
of a company hey bro what do you do oh I
have my own brand I'm an entrepreneur
I'm crushing and Joey I'm not picking in
you this is a general statement yeah
I've got my own business that's sexy I'm
an entrepreneur that's a rock star you
know like that's cool right now right
not as cool it's like hey bro what are
you up to
oh I'm like the junior assistant for
Ricky Thompson for her you know
underwear brand what what the college
for that so but I'm telling you right
now the person with the humility and the
patience to do the second scenario is
going to win every type ninety-nine out
of a hundred times just what's going to
happen I'm glad I got to say that glad
that came out it is true it's super true
and what [ __ ] hits the fan and it will
and people can't raise money and it's
not that easy
and you know in 3,000 bucks it's not a
lot of money to start a business
look just too much dreaming right now
question of the day wouldn't you been up
to I feel like that really you know like
a couple months here it feels like I'm
out of rhythm I'm gonna read every
single response to the comments here and
thank you so much for all the love on
dailyvee it feels like everybody's
really feeling what's going on over
there I appreciate that and I hope
you're well I miss you we're getting
close to the summertime it's gonna be
great India good job Sivan Gareth thank
you so much Facebook live you keep
asking questions I'll keep answering
them
what's up guys hope you enjoyed the show
please do I get to link it up anywhere
is it like in here or is it down below
is it in print or is it in my video
it'll be it's here down to my left
like right here there's a button for
them to subscribe to my youtube video
yeah it's a little buggy thing that's
right guys
click this that's right use that